[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast for
two lifelong friends talk about life for
a long time I'm wrecked and I'm linked
this week at the round table of dim
lighting
we are taking you to the summit we're
taking you to the peak we're giving you
a peek behind the scenes at the YouTube
Summit this is an invitation only event
that usually happens annually depending
on what's happening with like
Global Medical pandemic crises I think
it came to a stop but uh they they gave
us an invitation this year we're
authorized to talk about this and we
went I think we are never going to be
invited again I think we're not supposed
to talk about it but the stuff that
we're going to talk about yeah we're not
gonna We're not gonna talk about
anything that we shouldn't talk about
we're just going to kind of relay ours
I'm going to talk about everything that
I experienced
um and I want you to hear about it
because you know what these are like
um the youtubery of Youtubers of the
YouTube uh
and there's probably some sort of
threshold of people they invite because
they only have a certain capacity for
people to come to this thing and it's
probably like a
I don't know you gotta you gotta really
be successful on YouTube I mean
there's some criteria that they didn't
tell us about but I'm glad we were
invited everyone here everybody is
succeeding on YouTube everybody that we
we talked to there that we if I didn't
know him or if I didn't know him it
turns out that they're all successful
catastrophically
uh popular catastrophic I think it's
different it was different stages it
depend that you know it was interesting
and that's one of the things that I the
reason uh
I was I was saying hey why don't we talk
about this on the podcast is because I
find myself
talking like I'm catching up with
friends and it's one of the first things
that comes to mind because right it's an
interesting thing that we went through
it's a weird event interesting people
and it's just one of those things that
uh happens just because of the job that
we have yeah an experience that we only
can have because of this weird career
that we have chosen and the fact that
this career has gone
unexpectedly well and there's not
another event that we can attend as
creators that's like this because
and I I mean they this may be the
seventh year that they've done it and
again during the pandemic for two years
they didn't do it but like seven years
ago was the first one which we we were
invited to that one
um I think I think we've always been
invited but we've only been able to go
to like the very first one we wanted to
go to some other ones busy manly and
then this is we're like we finally
were able to with our schedule say we
could do it because it was in Palm
Springs but the way that they do it can
you say that I just did man I don't know
if you can even say that where it was
I think we're gonna bleep that out Palm
Springs oh another Blue
Springs that one they had to bleep out
and put a black spot over here that was
two long beeps before we talk about it
but hold on what I was trying to say was
the thing that's weird about it and
different about it is they don't let you
bring your people you know whenever you
become a successful Creator you surround
yourself with people you have agents you
have managers you have all types of
um people doing all types of things
representation talk to the people talk
to my hand you know kind of a thing uh
none of that so it's you know as a
Creator you're going into this space
where the only people who aren't
creators are well you're YouTube
employees and it turns out that they're
gonna really want to talk to you about
making shorts I guess we can talk about
that later but my point is
you can rub shoulders with other
creators get to know them and it's and
there's less pretense because you don't
there's not a lot of people at the party
so to speak who want something from you
you once you get
traction on the internet and you start
to go to like business thrown parties
Mixed Company you go to mixers there's
some creators there but then there's
everybody else who's trying to get in on
that action and have these conversations
that they want something from you they
want you to be involved in something
they want they want to go into business
with you they have business cards they
have business cards we don't carry
business cards so they YouTube has done
a good job of creating a space where
you can just talk to other creators and
you know that there's much less pretense
when they when you talk to other
creators they're asking us questions
we're asking them questions it's a lot
more sincere it and you don't really
have to think as much what a what do
they get out of this conversation why am
I bored of tears and I can't get out of
this conversation after being in it for
40 minutes I mean there are some
creators that uh that I'll see it at an
event like this and we have like we've
got an ongoing conversation about
something that isn't even related to our
careers at all that we kind of pick up
and keep talking about like I'm you know
I'm not going to talk I'm not that's
just private stuff but like it's just
cool to have friends in the space to
kind of like catch up and commiserate
yeah well and just like connect with
somebody who there's a there's a select
group of people in the in the world who
understand what where the the job that
we're trying to do firsthand you know
firsthand and it's just it's cool to get
to talk to them because we don't we
don't we're not part of the scene like
we don't hang out with a bunch of
YouTubers nope there's a bunch of
YouTubers in L.A we don't hang out with
them because just be honest we don't
hang out with many people at all because
we do a lot of working and a lot of
familying
um and I love it so we're gonna we're
gonna talk a lot about that but I do I
did want to ask you a question I wanted
to catch up with you because I did see
that uh
Dr Emily Morse uh sex spurt who we had
on the show if you do recall during our
episode of sex Timber when we talked to
her uh and maybe mentioned some
Contraptions that go into certain places
on your body and I was the first to
break the seal on that
well she explained that she had some
things that she may send us and I will
say that we receive those things uh and
I'm you know what I feel like I'm not
even going to describe what it is
because if you want to go listen to
sextember you can and I don't
necessarily want to make I want to put a
disclaimer I don't have to put a
disclaimer on this but I just want to
ask you we received some things and have
you received have have you fully
received the thing that you received yet
thank you for asking
um because I have
that night
I that night I tested it out I'm
different than you I was like this needs
to be it was sitting over there on the
counter in my bedroom
this has to be for a special occasion my
wife was out of town
[Music]
I was I just felt like a Droid just
trying on a new part
listen I I I have I've set an
appointment to to try it out oh and with
a doctor I need to have proper
supervision
yeah I'm serious dude why are you
laughing you what you mean that you have
set a time with you and your wife to be
like this we're they're going to try
this yeah
uh I haven't told you that yeah you put
it on the counter is it on our shared
calendar it's not on your your blank
wrist that you keep looking at this is
an expression man it's not the 50s
here's the thing all Expressions started
with a reality so when I look at my
watch as a joke it's not that I think
that I have a watch on it's just a I'm
doing I'm doing a Time joke I mean it's
a joke so funny this is why you need
this is why you need to watch watch your
biscuits as long as as well as listen to
it well it comes out on video later I
just can't wait it came right out
because I use Lube so I will I I believe
that I will have she sent Lube as well a
report we don't have to bleep Lube do we
just don't keep saying it
um you can be like getting an oil change
man
Jiffy Lube you have to bleep that
[Laughter]
uh not a sponsor yeah Christy and I are
going on a getaway and I'm I'm bringing
it take it out on a getaway okay all
right
that's probably a good idea
I I'll I will let you know
so yeah I'll get I'll get back to you on
that okay all right emphasis on the back
I'm glad we could catch up about that
I'm feeling a little sluggish we just
took a little trip across town
um I don't know when this is coming we
don't do those a lot uh speaking of
YouTubers got to hang out with our our
boys Ryan and Shane over at Watcher uh
because we're doing you know they're all
on our Channel we're on there I don't
yeah that doesn't I don't think it comes
out until November though so get ready
for that yeah there's a little preview
set yourself an appointment you know
what I'm saying some some things you got
to work up to you just can't go home
that night and just watch us on that
channel you got to build up to it right
you gotta get you gotta loosen up you
got to be relaxed yeah you got to be in
the right frame of mind it depends on
your personality uh but I will say that
while we were on the other side of town
uh I remembered that and Jenna was with
us it was three of us
I remembered a place that Josh had
recommended
not Josh of course is uh
one foodie one of the culinary experts
around here and he's a mythical Chef
which means a fake Chef I guess no he's
very much a real Chef he has never led
me wrong when it comes to
a recommendation and this
town that you know I I love this town
one of the many reasons is all the food
and we were crawling so I just wanted to
say I felt like I built that up because
Josh built it up for me you may remember
that episode of
what's the show that we make good
mythical morning where we had corn smut
which
is essentially a fungus that grows on
corn
and it has like a truffle like flavor
and there's a different a different name
for it I can't remember the name of it
but corn smut is sort of the rough slang
name for it and this place the chef at
this what essentially is a taco stand
um where all the seating is outside it's
called bees b w e s yeah there's like a
flying bee tacos Taqueria is that how
you say that word yep am I saying that
right
um and the so this place they do the
corn smut and then what is the word did
I eat corn spot no so they don't do he
the chef does essentially like a coursed
out dinner I don't know if he still does
this but he does like a coursed out
dinner
of that's a corn smut like tasting and
he incorporates it into all the tacos
but you have to that's like he only does
like one a day certain days of the week
or something he has to call way ahead of
time I like Jesse and I went down there
one time because on Josh's
recommendation and we were going to have
the corn smut thing and he was like oh
Ollie that's one table a night and you
have to call like a month ahead of time
who knows now that I'm talking about it
it may be longer than that
um but anyway I wanted to make sure
y'all guys got a taste of these tacos
which
I just think that they're like the best
tacos in town I mean they were really
good tacos I feel a little weighed down
though because you stopped short on your
third taco and I wasn't prepared for
another Taco but you may stop short
my mind my one part of my brain said
just have a bite and then my body said
eat the whole taco and I did I noticed
that you started like I took a couple
bites and then I was like this is my
third Taco who am I fooling I'm not
going here yeah I'm done I'm listening
to my body and then I said would you
like the rest of my taco you listening
to your body tells you to stop eating
yeah I'm not even saying the opposite
about my body it's not being full and
then my body's like bring it so I give
it to you and I I noticed that you
started eating off of the other side
because that was my way of saying I'm
not going to eat all the way through the
taco to it I get to Link's border right
where my mouth I'm creating a rep border
on this side of the taco so I I thought
I I I just assumed that you were gonna
leave a sliver stop between I assume my
last day and your last I assumed as well
this is one of my brain I actually made
it easier for you to stop because there
was a border and even if it was just a
sliver that would have been a little
something but then I looked back a a
lightning clap later it's all gone and
it was gone and then I guess it's the
Thunder that collapsed but you know what
I mean and Jenna had essentially done
the same thing as you but she had
created a Jenna border on all three
tacos and had used discipline to stop on
all her tacos
and at this oh really my body said my
body said finish Jenna's tacos too
I thought you were
a guy did you do that no no because my
brain at that point kicked in and said
you do not need to do that you've got a
podcast to make
but you don't seem you don't seem way
down I'm a little sluggish I mean yeah
A little sluggish after that after I was
you know after I had dealt with uh Dr
Emily's gift and
um had extra extra half taco
I got to tell you I I mean I was you
know there was a little cup of beans and
I think that hurt me because like I was
in pain all the way home I didn't want
to tell you guys but like no I was in a
lot of pain I wouldn't be from I don't
think you can beans are gonna have a
gaseous effect within literally within
minutes yeah they do though it was 20
minutes
I don't know we need to Google that I
feel better now
I'll put it to you that way all right
here we go
um so let's talk about Palm Springs the
top secret well before invitation only
let's talk we got a YouTube event let's
talk quickly about the uh camping trip
that we went on uh with Stevie it
finally happened
uh we joked about it forever quite a
build up joke became a reality we
actually did it we created multiple
videos of our camping experience we
filmed it all it was quite quite the
camping trip we had a good time I think
it's going to translate into your
viewing experience
um we're going to release it on a
mythical Society because if when you pay
for the mythical Society you get what
you pay for or more
so it's a win-win you know so we're
putting this over there how are we doing
it we're available uh first second and
third degree
uh that's generous we uh this is this
came out on Friday uh you can so go to
basically just go over to mythical
society.com uh become a member if you
aren't one and watch the the camping
trip videos we had a good time
I'm not gonna say things got naughty
because they didn't oh they bring in my
toys but everything was good had a blast
join in the fun mythicalsociety.com
okay
um
I had how did you what was your um
disposition entering into the the
YouTube Creator Summit
um because going in as
what you might call an OG you know
you're going in as
one of the guys that's been doing this a
very long time yeah there were there
weren't that many people who were there
at the first one seven years ago and
uh I know Hank was there
Hank Green yeah
um there's a few other people uh uh I
just can't remember them all my mindset
was you know I was looking forward to it
you know it was I didn't have to get on
a plane we just drove to Palm Springs
which is not a it's not a great Drive
I mean you come out of LA and you think
you can go to Palm Springs and it's like
an hour and a half and then you you
Google it and it says
it can take anywhere from two to four
and a half hours to get to Palm Springs
like there's just something about the
way that the traffic flows out of L.A at
any time I'm talking about two o'clock
in the afternoon on the East Tuesday
going east out of town on a Tuesday in
the middle of the afternoon it's always
crazy it could take it could take over
twice as long it could take four and a
half hours I would say and that's
happened to me going any direction
because I've gone South before like
trying to get to San Diego
and then you don't leave before noon on
a Friday but we didn't have to get on a
plane six hour drive or something crazy
like that you'd get caught up in I was
pretty excited you know I think um I can
I can get in a mode to be social
well that's an understatement
well you know so it's like I kind of
like I can turn on being an extrovert
there was a certain point in the let's
see so it was we got there that
afternoon there was a mixer that night
you know you stay that night and it's
all the next day and then another night
and then the next day it's like a half
day worth of programming so we had two
nights uh one full day and then and a
half day so you can so at a certain
point I had to take I had to go to my
room for like an hour during the day and
like take a nap but other than that I
was in like I was in
what you might call link mode I wouldn't
call it an on switch I would call it the
dial broke and the dial came off you you
call this an on and off I consider it an
on well listen and then the dial is
broken I here's what I did you know I I
I considered you
which meant that like I was like you
know what
whenever we enter into like a mixer or
something like that I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go this way you can go that way
you know I just feel like I can give you
a little space
you know because
uh I mean it yeah definitely at one of
the people that we met that I like hit
it off with the Long Snapper we'll talk
more about later uh we were hanging out
and then like the next morning we were
hanging out again at breakfast
and in the middle of our conversation at
breakfast
he said
are you always like this
and I like took it as a compliment
because he kind of had a smile on his
face he was like are you always like
this and I'm like and what did he did
you say what do you mean by this I said
what you see is what you get that's what
I said what I didn't want to explain
like well you know what I don't get out
much and I don't make new friends and
this is this is a this is a fun
environment that's how you would explain
it I don't get out much and I don't
really meet people very often I don't I
can't sustain this level of energy if we
had like an ongoing friendship but like
over the course of like uh a retreat I'm
bringing
I'm bringing my energetic I'm bringing
my enthusiasm to this space because I
legitimately was excited about
connecting with people who spoke our
language and
um
I would they were interested in me I was
interested in them and uh but I do think
it was it was fun I think people might
be surprised and incidentally when we
got to the uh first sort of gathering
that night and you were like you went to
the bathroom
um immediately
and I was like you always go to the
bathroom first well I didn't because you
can you can pee and you can look in the
mirror okay I I don't like I don't like
I don't like showing up at a place and
walking around and talking to like five
people and then having to pee and then
looking in the mirror and realizing that
there's something fundamentally wrong
with my face well that might not be a
you can't change that though what do you
mean no I mean like it's not I guess
unfundamentally something that is easily
preventable but no one had the heart to
tell me because I was sparing you you
would have told me but like you know but
when you made that decision I mean we
didn't talk about it but I I do think
that for the most part you're saying
when I decided to go to the bathroom I I
went I just went to the party and yeah
you only talking to people uh because I
do think that well because you said you
framed it at the beginning as if you
were like I'm going to go over here I'm
but yeah we didn't discuss it that was
my frame of mind as well not just
because I knew you were going to be in
link mode and there's only so much room
for that
um which is true but it was more like we
get a lot more out of this experience
right right we divide and have multiple
conversations with people and get to
know each other and get to know more
people yeah and then we come back
together and we we trade notes and
sometimes
you'll have an interaction with somebody
a little bit later than me and then they
will realize that they've had the exact
same conversation with both of us only
separated by time because
we're us
maybe that's not the case though I think
that's less and less than the case okay
then let's talk about we can one of the
things we can talk about is what do we
talk to people about and then see if
we're giving people the same experience
like I talked to this one couple who
um
they were asking me they knew I had kids
they don't have kids
and they asked me
should I should I should we have kids
and I'm like
wow don't put me in this position this
is like
this is like the most fun of fundamental
talk about fundamental question that you
can ask I mean like this is your entire
life trajectory you're putting it in my
hands like I'm not I I can't tell you
whether you should have children very
interesting POV on this conversation and
so I'm like I'm like listen
uh and they were like well I mean just
tell us your perspective I was like oh I
have the answer
I'm just not going to tell you
because I don't want to be the one
who told you what you should do and then
you do it and then your life is either
amazing or screwed up I mean it's like
don't put this on me
and I think that's when you walked up
and I was like you know what you take it
from here
is that what happened yeah and so so
what did you tell them they asked so
here this is exactly what happened so
they said
um
we're going to ask you a question that
we just asked link
and then they ask the question should we
have kids and the first thing I said is
well what did link say and then
I think the exact words were he got very
belligerent
yeah yeah I was a
don't put me in that position
that's what I'm talking about
the dial being broke you're gonna shirk
your your responsibility on me is being
interpreted if you're asking me if you
should have children then no
no you shouldn't don't I mean we barely
know each other
um I think I think the question that
they were asking and this is how I
answered the question was
you have kids what is your perspective
on having kids and what would you say to
someone of our age who is considering it
so I just asked after I asked them what
did link say just because I wanted to
see what they would say and hoping for
an answer like they use the word
belligerent
um that's a little harsh the uh
I said okay well
I said something like what do you value
you know like what what is it that you
think you're after
okay with considering children and like
what is your what do you like about your
life right now
because I was like you ask me this
question
I'm a guy who comes from a very
particular background where I was on a
very particular plan where having
children very soon into a very young
marriage was part of the formula it was
not a decision it wasn't even a decision
right and now here's all the benefits I
have of being a 44 now 45 probably by
the time you hear this
um your old man
with an adult child and a teenage child
and now I'm getting I'm still young I'm
getting ready to have some fun man
you know the people we were talking to
were younger than us but older than we
were when we decided to have kids so and
and so then they were like well we feel
like we've kind of like traveled
everywhere that we want to travel we're
actually kind of looking to sort of
settle down I was like well that's you
know I'm not saying you should have kids
but
the fact that you're you're thinking
about settling down sometimes growing a
family is part is part of that process
so that's the way I interacted with the
question it wasn't
um I think that we we gave them the old
one two point one two Punch Baby see I
let them know that like this is not
something to take lightly yeah yeah you
really set it up for me I really set it
up yeah for you I'm glad I walked up I
was messing with them but I know but I
also felt like because
I didn't know them it wasn't like the
first time we ever met what's wrong with
this guy who I've never met like I've
had many endearing interactions with
this couple uh yeah like right before
the pandemic I saw him at a noodle shop
that was the first thing we talked about
um and that's why they because it was me
should we have these news it was me
Christy and Lando so they met Lando and
so they kind of knew they saw what the
family looks like they thought well they
saw part of it I got two other whole
children that weren't they saw enough
it's not enough to draw a conclusion so
it wasn't like who's this crazy person
like are you always like this
um they didn't ask me that yeah that was
the first thing you had just met yeah so
yeah yeah story's not really adding up
here I mean listen I knew these guys
unlike the other people that I went up
to that I didn't know
um well my Approach with people was uh
well first of all I I gotta say I'm sure
you experienced the same thing
there is this
there's always a question when you enter
an environment like this and of course
there's the people that we know and we
have been friends with for some time and
have been in this business for a long
time and they were pretty well
represented there
like the Hank greens of the world not
just not to say that Hank Green is a
genre of person but you know what I'm
saying people who've been on this
platform for a long time yeah he is one
in a he is one of a kind every time I
see Hank I'm like you are such a genre
um but to have the people that I did not
recognize
come up to me
and say hey I've been watching you since
I was eight I literally had a person say
that I've been watching you oh yeah I
was eight years old and then I had many
others say I've been watching you since
middle school right and they're like uh
18 20 22 24.
um
but it was cool because
you know you never know like this is a
big world that right this is you there's
con you don't have to get a license to
upload a YouTube video you don't have to
pass a test you just start doing it so
the trust me the entry point is you know
point of entry or whatever the barrier
to entry is non-existent so
but the people who've gotten to this
place where they've quickly grown a
platform it was just cool to be like hey
they're coming up to me and they're
asking me questions like that was
something that happened lots of people
asking questions like so like how how
you're still making videos like how are
you still how are you still making
videos how are you still relevant like I
heard you guys had built a big business
like how did you do that so
I would enter into that kind of
conversation
uh but most of the time what I was
trying to do is just I mean I didn't I
don't watch enough I don't watch very
much YouTube and I don't and I
definitely don't I think most people
that I was meeting were new to me their
content was new to me completely new to
me oh yeah so I would always be like
well tell me about your channel what do
you do what's your content yeah that's
not what I do
what I did was so I was sitting down at
another time and there was this like
young guy
I would say I don't know 21.
could have been could have been younger
um and I had seen his content
and I said uh a little bit of it
and I said you know what I love your
content you're like doing doing the
lifestyle vlogging thing like you and
your girlfriend I just wanted to show
them like I know what's up with you and
he was like uh
I
me my girlfriend I was like yeah you and
well I was like she's in a lot of the
thumbnails and he was like
you got the wrong guy that's me that's a
character I play Oh and I was like
okay yeah yeah I've been watching real
close yeah yeah yeah you're doing great
you're doing great there I mean you are
she's I think I was great I think I'll
stick with my method yeah and then I
ended up explaining
I was like you know the truth of the
matter is I have watched your content
but I'm getting you confused with
somebody else because yeah and I was
explaining the because he was a mythical
accelerator candidate you know what and
I'm sitting there like we're trying to
invest oh yeah in you and your
girlfriend we're really excited about
you and your girlfriend we're trying to
invest in creators and like so there's
people who look at creators maybe we
should have stuck together this person
is interesting maybe and uh you should
check them out do you want us to follow
up and I'm like I just look at the
channel I look at stuff and I'm like
yeah follow up you should write a book
called how to dig a hole immediately and
then try to get yourself out of it
throughout this conversation
it's fun like
you know it there's a post-pandemic part
of this that's like I've been [ __ ]
cooped up you know kind of a thing
that's like you get back out there are
you saying this is a long coveted
symptom it's with pull cart and you know
are you saying that you just yeah this
is a longer you're just I mean I'm
suffering from my own version of log
coaches you gotta start conversations I
don't get out much but you know I'm just
you know in a sense it is what you see
is what you get like I'm being very
sincere I thought he and his girlfriend
made great content yeah and he he just
is his girlfriend right I mean it's
actually a compliment some of the time
so convincing
um and he was like yeah I've been
watching you guys since Chia Lincoln and
I was like oh okay yeah maybe let's
let's keep talking
we can still make this work have I have
I screwed this up I so the people that I
don't like putting on airs
okay I'm not I'm not saying you are
I just all the only thing I've said is
that I say tell me about your content
yeah that's fair that's how I started
yeah I'm not saying that's an air
um so that's it fair but the thing okay
so I I have I want to talk to you about
the people that I met and the way that I
learned their story and then the way
that I ended up hyping them up to other
people at the Creator Summit so okay
I don't know I don't know I walk up to
this guy can't remember
young guy I think he's actually like 25
or so but I didn't I thought you know
early 20s whatever yeah and uh so I'm
like just tell me like tell me your
story what do you do
and he's like well
I used to work at Cold Stone fair and I
was like well I'm not interested in your
resume like I didn't ask you what you
did before you know this is uh this is
pertinent information he was like I
worked at Cold Stone
and I put an iPhone like right here
under my chin it's giving you a POV of
what I was doing at Cold Stone and of
course at Cold Stone if you haven't been
to one if if you're outside of America
maybe you haven't been to one but this
is basically like where you're taking a
ball of ice cream and rolling it around
and mixing it up with the ingredients on
like a piece of marble you're under
selling it I mean they have two frozen
mallets and they have it's like it's
pretty awesome they artistically mush
the ice cream together and they call
them fold the ice cream in with mix-ins
so he says I started doing this and I
was just doing these POV videos and
posting them to tick tock originally
yeah and they were getting all these
views people just love this content
and I'm like okay well I'm just this is
me in my mind I'm like wow okay
he says then uh I started you know I
kind of talked to Cold Stone maybe it
was going to become something where I'm
you know I'm working for Cold Stone am I
gonna work for Cold Stone as a guy who
makes these videos long story short is
because Coldstone is a typical
Corporation with a bunch of
you know people who don't understand how
this stuff works involved
they couldn't figure out a way to work
with them in a way that made sense so
what did he do
he went and started his own ice cream
shop
in New York City today
and here's what he does first of all his
name is Dylan Dylan Lemay you probably
if he's cool if you know this content
you know this content because the dudes
have got millions of subscribers and all
kinds of views and really the shorts on
YouTube so now he so officially and a
lot of creators there at the at the
summit were people who had gotten
initial traction on Tick Tock and then
because of the YouTube shorts program
you know short vertical videos 60
seconds or less they've gotten all this
traction on YouTube and their subscriber
accounts have gone up really really fast
so these people have grown faster on the
platform in terms of views and
subscribers than any previous generation
of any wave of YouTube way faster like
ridiculous of millions of views on each
short maybe pushing 100 million views on
the show yeah and he's got some huge
videos but he makes multiple videos a
day so he opens up his ice cream shop
called catching ice cream and it's it's
basically a gimmick ice cream shop where
this is where he makes his content he's
still doing his POV videos but now he's
got these balls of ice cream cream that
have stuff on them or whatever and he
throws you the freaking ice cream and
you catch it in a bowl at the place
catching ice cream what and so he's
telling me what if you don't catch it
they clean it up and they give you
another one
he says what if you don't catch that one
at that point it gets uncomfortable and
they begin to say okay listen
if this if you don't catch it this time
we're gonna kick you out I asked him
these same two questions uh I never
talked to this guy I never met what
happens if they miss it what happens if
they miss it again and he was like if it
doesn't happen he love your girlfriend
in it and then he was like and sometimes
you just take it and you just put if
they can't catch it you just put it in
there
and this is a young kid this is cool you
know he's in his 20s
crazy success he's got this ice cream
shop in Manhattan they just literally
opened just a couple months ago so it's
just trying to just manage all he opened
an ice cream shop to create YouTube
shorts and Tick Tock content it was that
was the means to these he's basically
taking
short form tractions or Tick Tock and
YouTube shorts and immediately
translating it into a brick and mortar
business which happened at such a scale
I mean it's such a a quick timeline
anyway so I'm talking to him did he
throw anything in your mouth I requested
him to throw at that point for the rest
of the time there I would go and just
point at food and he would throw it in
my mouth that's how I consumed all the
food for the rest okay okay cool
so I'm talking to so I I don't believe
it a night later I'm gonna I'm sure you
got people you want to talk about too
I'm going to finish the Dylan story
because there's there's more people I'll
come back to but
so I had that conversation with him the
next night I get into a conversation
with somebody who's been on the platform
for nearly as long as us Linus Tech tips
and so if you know if you know if you
care about you know
Tech stuff and you watch YouTube videos
you already know about Linus Tech tips
huge Channel huge business he's based in
uh Vancouver Vancouver so
and lots of lots of things in common
with the way that he's built his
business and the large business a lot of
employees and so we we had a long
conversation just about what it's like
to be a Creator who started this Channel
and all of a sudden you're running this
Media Company it's a very cool
conversation absolutely seven years ago
at the First YouTube Summit we weren't
talking to anybody who had 70 employees
like I believe he has yeah something
like that and now we have 130. you know
it's like this strange
phenomenon that we've been able to ride
these waves so like to be able to
connect was and yeah I was in the I was
in the beginning of that conversation
well and so I'm talking to him we're
getting to know each other as guys who
are aware of one another but have never
actually met and connected yeah Dylan
ice cream man
comes into the conversation
and I was like I thought I thought if
Linus didn't know the didn't know about
him I was like hey tell him you know
this guy he's like nausea tell him your
story man oh you're a Matchmaker and uh
you're connected is like well I make ice
cream I said no no man start from the
cold stone yeah baby tell it like you
told it to me that's right and he's
telling it and then I'm I'm literally
like crying like his dad oh because I'm
I'm like hey what are you tell me the
ice cream shop what do you do what do
you do when somebody drops it I I I'm
yeah I'm hyping him up man yeah because
he's too humble he was just being too
humble about it I was like dude you got
to be full of yourself and make it on
YouTube you worked at Cold Stone and now
you don't know your own ice cream shop
in Manhattan because you can freaking
film yourself do it
during that same conversation
another guy crowd-formed answers
uh
again if you know you know because these
guys are so popular Malad okay very
similar story this guy his parents own a
Subway
he's doing the same thing he's a
Sandwich Artist filming himself making
sandwiches are they holding the phone
between their chin and their collar is
that like no or do they have them do
they have like a harmonica maybe now
they did that in the early days but
since then they have some sort of Mount
because that would be crazy
and this is what they do they film
themselves doing something and then they
do a voiceover very calm voice over
that often is completely unrelated to
the thing that they're making it's it's
this kind of like
break your brain a little bit if your
gin X Millennial ziniel what we are okay
um because this is again I'm sounding
like an old man but
because it to me it's weird right can't
you can't break me you're showing me and
you're answering a question that's
unrelated
and this is what the kids want man now
sometimes it'll be like what's the
craziest sandwich that I what's the
craziest sandwich that anybody ever
asked for it was meatballs and tuna and
he's making the meatballs of tuna then
he turns the camera on himself and he
eats it at the end oh he you okay so he
does eat it so this guy owns I mean this
guy uh this guy's parents own a Subway I
think they probably still do he's still
doing the sandwich thing but now he's
expanded his content and he was one of
the people that was like I've been
watching you since I was seven years old
and he is still doing this stuff and
then now he's doing something with Jimmy
with Mr Beast he's got some he's like
eating Mr Beast Burgers on his I
but again I it was one of those things
that it's cool man we get so in the in
the weeds necessarily with what we're
doing what we're trying to accomplish
and also with just running a business it
just takes time yeah it was nice to pull
our heads out of each other's asses and
then well yeah and then
talking to these these for lack of a
better word kids
who are making this content with an
iPhone strapped onto a thing on their
bodies doing these POV content and
they've been watching us
since they were kids and they're doing
this stuff that is so like yeah we're
doing food content but it's two dudes at
a desk trying things and making videos
that are 15 to 20 minutes long and we're
doing what we do and we're not going to
change what we do uh to any yeah
hold a phone between my chin I mean I
can try it right now
but those kinds of stories well
like the cameras that you'd be filming
your Google because the camera is the
wrong way can you see me
[Music]
can you see me it can you see me making
a sandwich I I think that man your shaky
hands would disqualify you from doing
that kind of content but it was it was
inspiring
it's inspiring to hear like oh man is it
the only on the Internet only because of
the internet and only because of social
media platforms like YouTube
can this kind of thing happen where you
just and it's here's the thing I want to
be very clear about be clear
I I don't look at this stuff and get uh
annoyed or angry or I love it or have
this like what this is dumb he's just
making sandwiches to me I'm like he's
just making sandwiches and yeah it's
crazy yeah and he's getting this kind of
traction because he's doing more than
that and he's got this POV not just the
people it's deceptively brilliant
because it's it's they've created a
genre of content they've created a new
genre that I go home that night and I'm
at a birthday party that I've taken
Shepherd to and I'm having dinner with
uh the parents of of this kid and their
like 12 year old daughter is there and
I'm telling them about my experience and
I'm telling them exactly what I've just
been telling you this guy this this ice
cream guy and then the 12 year old girl
who's completely
consumed by her phone looks up and says
you met Dylan
and I was like yeah and I was like and I
met milage you met Malad and and I go
through the people that I met and who
were making the short form stuff and
it's like this is what this is what
she's watching I love it if I I can't
say it enough I I love it it is
inspiring meanwhile I'm at the other end
of the party with the group of people
that I'm talking to and I'm like
I'm gonna sext my wife
and they're like what I'm like
see that see that guy over there serving
pasta next to a cheese wheel there was a
freaking cheese wheel that was like he
was scraping he's in a hot spoon and
scraping cheese out of this cheese wheel
and putting it on pasta and I'm like
here take my phone take a picture of me
behind this cheese wheel and like
Christy loves cheese
so if you love you so
take my picture so I texted Christy and
I said can I sext you
now you know what I've you know what I'm
sorry to say I've never sexted my wife I
just not that's just not something we've
ever tried you know I'm sure you have
hey I'm red I have been sitting on this
egg for a while it's time to hatch it oh
a sex my wife all the time this isn't
about you right now well you've
submitted about me I haven't sexted my
wife
I've done other things with the phone
okay great and I don't mean I put it in
things I I'm not saying put it below
your chin and you're trying to get
that's not a good angle I'm trying to
create a new a new genre
top down that's just well okay so anyway
she doesn't reply and I'm like well
take the picture and then send so I get
back in front behind I asked the guy I
was like do you mind if I take your
spoon and stand next to the cheese wheel
and the first picture I took was like
more of like uh hold on you took the
chef's spoon he was he was for it well
uh turns out they were taking pictures
of me talking to the guy so you can see
that I'm getting consent in the pictures
that I'm now showing and then he moved I
was like I I don't I had to explain to
him I don't want you in the picture
because he turned and started smiling at
the camera and I was like I don't this I
need to I'm trying to sex my wife I
don't want you in the photo can you just
stand over here and then I just stood in
front of the cheese wheel and at first I
was like
uh like I was just like
I don't know spluge in on the cheese
wheel I don't know I just kind of go you
know I was at a party
yeah and and then then after that uh all
of my friends got in the picture and
we're like we're taking pictures all
your friends all my friends at the party
that I'd make all the people that you
just met yeah yeah yeah we were having a
good time
and they were loving it they were like
this is so crazy I'm taking pictures I'm
taking pictures that Link's gonna send
to his wife and then uh Christy never
got back to me yeah right that night and
then um was she asleep if she was she
was asleep and then um so then I
actually I didn't send the picture
because I was waiting for her to say yes
I would like for you to sext me or
whatever she was gonna say and then when
I woke up the next morning
um she had said something I think but it
wasn't
I can't remember it wasn't related so
then I was like oh no no this is what
happened I went back when I got back to
my hotel room and I'm like sitting there
about to go to bed and like Christy had
texted me by that point
and I hadn't seen her response so then I
didn't and then I knew that she was like
I'm going to bed so I Knew by the time I
got to my room she was asleep so that
when she got my sex it would be in the
morning so I was like I don't want to
send the one where my eyes are rolled
back in my head I'm going to send one
that just kind of looks like I'm a
normal guy in front of a cheese wheel
it's more of a morning
cheese I thought you guys like to have
morning sex though
yeah I just didn't feel like that's the
type of thing she wanted to wake up to
so I sent her the other one and like she
the good thing is she knew that like
even though I was in party mode and
making friends that I was thinking about
her yep
and um and then the next morning
everybody was asking like what did she
say what did she do and I told them what
I told you and it was kind of like an
anti-climactic she uh she didn't respond
yeah she she thought it was she thought
it was sleep she said very sexy oh she
did so she she's she's playing along
very sexy is is what she said
uh I did see that cheese wheel and I uh
uh because what the guy was doing
uh which again I didn't eat any of it
though yeah well this is this did you
eat some difference between me and you I
saw a guy uh putting risotto into a
cheese wheel of Parmesan mixing it into
the to the parmesan and then putting
like truffles on top of it and I didn't
think about my wife I thought about the
risotto and I wanted to eat it until I
did oh
um
I did think about my wife later but in
that moment the cheese wheel definitely
took up 99.9 of my brain space that's
fair and it was very good of course I
did take the plate of risotto around and
people were like what are you eating
because it was it just looked like slop
on a yeah just risotto on a plate the
only thing I ate was like they had like
little little bites of chicken parm
that's several and yeah and I would I
took one it would be one bowl with a
little fancy schmancy little square of
chicken parm and then so I took that one
and then I took more
because I realized I realized past tense
that like I hadn't been eating but I had
been drinking so you can kind of start
to connect the dots so and I'm like I
need to eat so then I just I started
taking so that's how you realize that
you need to eat I need to eat versus I'm
hungry and I go on eat it's like I don't
want to be belligerent
I need to eat so then I had to like
recreate a full chicken parm on one
plate with like seven
well there was multiple there was a lot
there was multiple Foods there was a it
was I didn't I'll tell you all about the
food I didn't want any of the other food
because I went around this is what this
is what I do when I get to a party
I'd I go to the bathroom and you've
already eaten everything once no I go
around and I every single thing because
the foods get they change they get cold
I want to know what I like I want to
know what I want to go back for so I got
the chicken parm they had an eggplant
parm on the other side they in between
they had a
cup of charcuterie that was like rolled
up stuff in like
cheese and salami and bread that was
like artisanally put in this cup I got
that twice I didn't even see that and
then they had the risotto uh uh what
else do they have and then they had some
dessert later on which also ate
yeah but lesson learned don't get a
drink and eat at the same time because
then you've got you're holding a drink
and you've got a plate of food yeah so
you you either drink first or eat first
but don't do them at the same time right
and I had to learn that that was my like
covid leftover like forgetting how to go
to a party because I was sitting there
talking to people and I had to drink and
then I was looking for a table and then
the next thing you know so I put my
drink down on the table so I can eat and
a waiter comes and takes it and I was
like completely one at a time complete
party Foul but I think you're learning I
mean if you're going to a party with us
just stick with Rhett like he not he's
like hey stand over here like when we
went to the rings of power Premiere I
took Lily you took Shepherd so the four
of us are hanging around and like Rhett
comes up to me at like when they start
bringing food out and he's like no the
what we had we had split up a little bit
Yeah Lily and I met some other people
and then all of a sudden
red comes up to me and he's like I
figured out the best place to stand to
get the food they come out of this door
right here no no this isn't something I
figured this out at every party yeah
what door do the people come out of with
the food there's some come over here so
at every party there is a kitchen right
there is a there is a room or a kitchen
in which the food is being prepped and
delivered from
and
that's the source and you set up and you
know what you you don't want to like
stand outside the kitchen yeah you want
to be the first point
that counts as being at the party yeah
but is it the first person that they run
into when they come out and here's what
happens so the people who serve at these
parties if you go to a Premiere or you
go to any of these parties where there's
people walking around with places betray
people
would you like uh here's the thing about
would you like a song so raw thing now
see you're you're already making fun of
these people but these people who are
have the trays they're Working Class
People right come on don't make me the
bag no no no here's what I'm saying the
only normal people at these parties and
I'm talking about typical like premieres
and Hollywood parties are the people
serving the food everyone else is a is a
full of themselves celebrity like me and
you it's true okay and so but here's
here's what you learn really quickly is
that the people serving the food who are
just people trying to make it just they
might be an actor a struggling actor
struggling artist but they're at this
party I can't believe you're making it
about this and no seriously though what
they want to do is they don't like
walking around with this food and having
these people who are so full of
themselves
up at the food belligerent people turn
these these people especially in L.A
they turn their noses up at Food what
Jesse and I because Jesse's just like me
she wants to eat just like me yeah that
doesn't fit my diet she and I have
figured out that you make friends with
the trade people and then they're like
every time I go to this couple they get
they say yes to whatever I bring them
and the big man drains it and so it's
like they get their quote you get their
quote the food people yeah you can have
like normal conversations with them too
because they're not putting on heirs
they're not there to impress they're
there to work and I just find that you
come get me come get me when you bring
in a slide homie I I was at uh we went
to one Premiere and on the way out one
of the tray guys came up and he was like
hey
I'm wearing Josh sharer's pants
that's mythical Chef Josh yeah I was
like
he's like I'm Josh's brother-in-law
and he had I have to be a trade person
and I needed pants he had just just
moved and I think just moved into town
or whatever and he was like I had to do
this last minute and I needed pants and
I'm using I'm wearing Josh's pants I
thought those are the people that you
want to talk to at a party the people
with the food I thought you were going
to say when we were leaving the rings of
power uh Premiere and if you've watched
rings of power like in the first two
episodes there's this guy who he comes
down in a comment okay and he lands and
like this precursor to a hobbit or
basically a migratory Hobbit finds this
naked dude have you figured out who he
is you've I only I haven't watched
basketball well by the time this comes
out I think people will know it's but
that's not really what this is about at
this point in the story you don't know
who this mysterious guy I think it's
Gandalf it's not you fell from the sky
he fell from the sky and he's like
he makes fire around him but he doesn't
nothing's hot to the touch and he
doesn't he he has Amnesia and he's big
but he's got a lot of hair and he's a
he's a skinny white guy with a big beard
and as you were leaving the premiere
when we had just watched these first two
episodes and everybody's like who is
this guy
hand off shut up about that
what this a woman comes up to you and
says what she said
did you
you played you played the wizard in the
show
and I was like thank you yes
she's like you did great I was like I
appreciate that it's like he didn't have
any lines
multiple people have texts he just
tweeted at me saying he just laid down
in the fetal position and like people
think about me like people on the
internet think it's me it's just a guy
with long hair and a beard I don't know
there's not many of us does that mean
there's not many of you I mean it might
be red it's It's gotta be red I just
didn't want to get into the conversation
of like I she well here's what I thought
if my brain was working really quickly
as I was leaving you were leaving and I
said to myself I don't want to have this
conversation but also if I say yes to
this she gets to go home saying I met
that guy I met that guy and so I just
thought you don't know who he is yeah
what character he plays The Stranger is
what he's been called two other guys I
met which again just it is I'm back to
the YouTube Summit this is uh capturing
the
specificity man another guy comes up
again this guy was
and watched our content since he was a
kid
and I was like what do you do and he
says
I make dental content
Dental digest what
and then he shows me his channel
and I immediately I'm like oh boy
it's like 10 million subscribers
um millions millions of views he showed
you his channel on his phone
yeah this is like a that's like his
version of a business card I look but I
asked him I asked him his channel is he
working on people's mouths is he
is it tooth extraction like I'm I'm not
into that no he is
eating candy
okay okay first of all he's in Dental
School
he's going he's going to be a dentist
y'all okay
he eats candy
and then he brushes his teeth yes he
brushes his teeth so he's like
these Mexican candies versus cat my
teeth versus these it's basically like
eat a bunch of candies from a particular
place or whatever and do they cause
cavities and the way that he finds us
out again this is a dental student
he brushes his teeth and then he checks
the pH of his teeth
of his mouth because the pH of your
mouth after you one of the reasons that
you get cavities apparently is the pH
changes that take place when there's all
these sugar bugs or not sugar bugs but
sugar in your mouth sugar bugs are those
his words are yours I think he does use
the word sugar bugs because I think
bacteria feed on sugar when it's in your
mouth and so it does promote the growth
of unhealthy bacteria which then
contributes I don't know how teeth work
I didn't go to dental school and I don't
haven't watched much Dental digest other
than what I was shown in the moment
but then but he brushes his teeth and he
brushes his teeth
oh so I talked to this guy for quite
some time
he had a lot of questions about growing
a business and I was and you had a lot
of questions about brushing your teeth I
did I was like tell me about those
Mexican candies again so then
literally 30 minutes later I started
talking to another guy and I'm like what
do you do and he's like
uh I make dental content and I was like
whoa whoa whoa whoa we've already broken
there's not many people here bro
I just talked to another guy he said oh
yeah I know on Dental digest yes
and this is uh guys a little bit older
who is an orthodontist again these
that's a different thing I know but he
is making like he's also he should team
up he's doing multiple things so this is
like the dental Power Rangers he's the
bintist
like I guess his name's Ben the dentist
and so he's got his content that's doing
great doing great on shorts as well and
he's got a whole different thing well
he's like answering questions he does a
lot of different things based on like
quickly looking at his channel but
we got in a group of I don't know 100 of
these YouTubers
um that have been invited to this event
because they're things are really really
working on the platform for them
two of them two percent of them
are dental guys
and this content is just
so popular it's crazy like everybody's
got teeth I mean a lot most people
wow and then I mean while I'm on the
other side of the party like having my
cheese wheel sext fun yeah and I looked
I look I look over there at one of the
people I'm I'm just talking to
I well I talked to the guy who turned
out to be an NFL Long Snapper and then
his wife comes over and I was like I'll
be damn if that's not an Olympian like
that is I know who that is I know who
that is but I don't want to have to ask
her who she is because I've seen her on
a box of Wheaties but her name is on her
antagonist Sean Johnson and I looked at
her tag and it said Sean Johnson well
actually it said she's my new best
friend Jenna are you freaking out you
what do you want you want to text her
yes
yeah we can do that right now I did not
say sexter by the way I'm not so it's
actually Sean East because she she
married Andrew East and here's the thing
I love both of them I am obsessed hey
guys love you here's the thing about we
have some fun I I I I'm a big fan of
both of them
Andrew in particular just do family
vlogging now because he is a Long
Snapper and I am recently obsessed with
long snapping because I listened to this
episode on some podcast where they were
talking about long snappers
and again if you're not familiar with
football this is the guy don't say with
that tone this is the guy who
bends over and throws the ball between
his legs to like a punter or somebody
who's kicking the about to hold the ball
to kick the ball and is he a short ways
away he's a long way a long ways away
and it's this position that was
marginalized for many many years because
it would be like long Snappers over the
years as the specialization of different
positions has developed in the NFL it's
kind of like a mirror of YouTube the
importance of a Long Snapper is so
important in fact
the the the joke is if you hear a long
Snapper's name during the game that
means they screwed up because No One's
Gonna Be Like The Long Snapper did a
great job tonight you only fight if
that's your job if you screwed up that's
when people find out and the Long
Snapper for the Carolina Panthers is JJ
Jansen who's been he hasn't he's like
Ben he hasn't missed a game in like 12
years I think he holds the current
record of any active player or something
but I'm just fascinated with this
position and I find out
Andrew was a Long Snapper I knew it ten
years I knew you were going to be
enamored with him once I passed him off
to you and but he came back to me the
next morning and asked me if I was
always like this
right and uh he didn't ask me any
questions like that but I asked him a
lot of questions about long snapping and
uh it was just it was fascinating again
do they get hit hard because the reason
why you're snapping it so long is so
that the punter has more time to keep on
it you have to block so then you block
you you're getting you're getting
damaged well
first of all he had a pretty face you
have to be well he's wearing a helmet
you have to be if if you're at any
position on the football field you're
going to be in shape and you're going to
be relatively big I guess unless you're
like the kicker play for the Redskins so
this is nope
well when he played they were called the
Reds yeah I think it's called the
Washington football team now and I don't
know if they've got a new name I don't
know he played for multiple teams they
don't have a mascot at all they were
like screw it no I think they're coming
totally messages they're coming up with
a new one we're not even going to mascot
territory but uh
but you after as soon as you snap it you
have to turn it you have to block
somebody but you're blocking somebody
who's really close to you and then
you're probably just wrapped up with
them for the most of the place what did
you you talk to him about this no I just
said hey uh no joke I'm not just saying
this because you're a Long Snapper but
I'm kind of obsessed with long snapping
ever since I heard about this the
specialization of this position and how
they're now recruiting kids in middle
school oh to become long Snappers and
there's a couple of long snapping
coaches he was like yeah so and so and
so and so of course he knew who these
people were and and he's also a long
snapping coach oh isn't this the thing
that once like in the past year or two
they changed College regulations to
where you can sponsor people you can
sponsor people and your idea was for us
to have a mythical Long Snapper yeah
well we originally I my my initial idea
before I became obsessed with long
Snappers was to just spot like a weird
position and then I find out about long
Snappers that's it that's it let's do it
and I don't necessarily know if we need
to sponsor one we what if we sponsored
all of a bunch of longstones yeah let's
let's really like just like the Long
Snapper fund right so Andrew we're going
to be talking to you about I talked to
him about it I told him the idea I said
we've been talking about it there could
be something oh you taught him about
that yeah yeah I said like I feel like
there's content here
you know follow a Long Snapper through
the season because it's such a specific
position so listen don't do that show
before we do
if you see a Long Snapper show
I don't know that somebody stole our
idea I don't think he can be done
without us I mean we're obviously very
instrumental in whatever Long Snapper
content makes his way on the internet no
but I do want to do it I think we will
begin the thing that I talked to him
about was
um he told me this story that he was in
uh uh when he was in a I think he he was
in a fraternity or he went to a he went
to a party with some of his teammates
and he he did not drink so he said
instead of drinking I'm gonna do the
gallon challenge so every time you drink
alcohol I'm gonna drink milk until I've
drunk a whole gallon of milk because you
know they say you can't do that right
and I'm not condoning for anyone to do
that because I don't know what it does
to your body but apparently at a certain
point milk does a body good I remember
Jason Batson I told him this I was like
when we were in middle school one day he
did he got all the everybody's milk
cartons and a like a gallon equivalent
of milk cartons and over that lunch
period like people just started hearing
the murmurs of like Jason Batts is doing
he's gonna drink a gallon of milk today
he wasn't drinking a gallon of milk
because we didn't really understand the
gallon challenge at that point it was
just Jason Batson's gonna drink all the
milk it was it was much let me
calculated much like the gallon
challenge he
he just up chucked everywhere it was he
was embarrassed listen I don't even
think he got into double digits oh my
gosh
it didn't it it ended quick for him so
he told me that um yeah he went to this
party he went to this frat party after
he had been like participating in his
his Challenge and right when he got to
the party he had to run to the bathroom
and he said that like it was one of
those things it's like you know you're
getting to the door and it's just like
you just can't hold it anymore and just
like as he flung the door open he just
like vomited everywhere in this house
he's like you wonder how you wonder how
it just gets everywhere like how
somebody just totally destroys a
bathroom it's like well I know because I
was that guy and I was like and then how
long did you spend in there just trying
to clean it up he was like no comment at
all yeah you got to leave you got to get
out of it so then I told him my story of
like when we were in Park City and we
met uh our high school friend Eric and I
I'm really developing a reputation here
I don't really drink that much but when
I do I I really have a story to tell I
don't really drink that much but when I
drink I drink that much
I was just I was just felt really sick
the next day and we sat at this coffee
shop and I was embarrassed to tell him
that I was hungover and like the sun was
just baking in and baking in and
at least my recollection now is that he
ordered some food I think it was an egg
but I don't know what it was and I saw
it it was maybe like a sunny side up egg
it made me sick to look at it I ran to
the bathroom and the same thing happened
to me I was like dude I know how you
feel and then I just hurled on every
vertical surface in that bathroom but
then I just spent the next 15 to 20
minutes just like pulling paper towels
out and just like mopping everything
down
and then I come back out finally and uh
you're like what happened I was like no
it just there was a line I don't
remember what I said but I felt horrible
I've actually felt better going very
slow that's what I taught them about so
no real long snapping
I asked him at one point if he was ever
in the Olympics
he said no and I just gave him a hard
time I don't know if he was like I
played in the NFL I was like yeah but
you you weren't on a Wheaties box I
don't know if I've ever met a gold
medalist she was also on a Cheerios box
and I was like that's the ticket and
also let me say that uh Andrew and Sean
were on our our team we divided up into
teams and our team you know first of all
excavator it was a scavenger hunt and
that involved some athletic stuff and I
looked at our team and I was like we
have a former NFL player and an Olympian
on our team if we don't win this problem
it's a problem and we did we won it's
the problem team yellow won the whole
thing
um but just the aspect of
I mean between all the goofing off it
like you're saying it was nice to have
um
conversations with people where
they valued our experience and we were
fascinated with theirs and how there's
so much overlap in where they're going
and what they're trying to build and
what we're already what we've already
built in a lot of ways and just how we
can kind of pay it forward and help them
out but also there's so much for us to
learn at the same time because like the
emphasis on shorts is a is a is a
totally new thing for YouTube like
grappling with the tick tock of it all
and
um so this everyone there has a spirit
of taking these tools and what the
algorithms how they behave being a
student of
finding the intersection between
technology and self-expression to reach
an audience and connect with them and I
and I just found that very invigorating
you know and it was it was it was cool
to be
seen as people who were
ogs still relevant and valuable to their
experience I mean Stevie was invited to
be a a speaker one of the speakers there
talking about there were like four
breakout sessions that everybody could
go to and they happened twice so they
ended up being like small groups so she
came to Palm Springs to talk about
building a team which a lot of YouTubers
are interested in doing and it's it's a
hard thing to figure out we weren't
allowed to see her we want I did see her
how did you see her I walked up to her
before her thing and she was and she
immediately started laughing because I
was wearing my my glasses and my shorts
and my palm spring shirt and she was
like you really look Palm Springs right
now it's like well and I'm having a ball
and she was like well you got to get out
of here but I would you know I'm I'm
proud of what we have at mythical that
it's not just about the two of us it's
about our team and like Stevie
represented him being there and like
lots of people like even people who've
been around the block many times like
Marquez saying he got a lot out of her
um her session
it is really cool and then they had this
thing called a magic mirror where you
could go up to it like a mirror mirror
on the wall you ask them something about
YouTube and then you get a response and
I don't know exactly how it worked but
we were supposed to go in and answer
people's questions
but we interacted with the mirror there
was a guy I don't know if you knew this
rep but there was a guy behind the
mirror he was speaking through a speaker
so it looked like the mirror was talking
I know which that guy was too and then
when we came out after interacting with
this guy like the YouTube person was
like how did it go and I was like
honestly he was kind of an [ __ ] and
then you said
uh well like he's a mirror he's just
reflecting back what he gets from you
and I was like oh okay yeah
uh but he was a fan so like we were
giving each other I he knew who we were
I was giving him a hard time he's
freaking married he was playing a
character well one of the things too I
didn't hurt his feelings I don't think
no one of the things that
um I'll say
is obviously okay YouTube
Not Perfect Right YouTube is a is a
corporation obviously their goal as part
of Google is to grow make money right
um but we have over the course of this
our career gotten to know the people who
work at YouTube
and
when it comes to
places where you can make videos right
if you're just a Creator and you say
okay well I can make videos on Tick Tock
I could do things on Instagram I can do
things on Facebook I could do things on
whatever the platform is and we do
things everywhere we put content
everywhere
but there's only there's one platform in
which you actually have a connection
with the people who are making these
decisions and feel like oh if I have a
complaint or if I have this idea or is
it obviously we're privileged in that
we've been on the platform for a really
long time and we have a lot of
subscribers and we have a big so that we
and not everybody has no it's true of a
certain level of creation But ultimately
I'm saying is that
they're not doing a perfect job by any
means but they're doing a much better
job there isn't a close second there's
no other platform that is actually
catering to and listening to uh the
creators and understanding that the
people who make the content on their
platform are the heart and soul of the
platform and people get mad at YouTube
because they you know people get mad at
everybody about everything that's just
kind of the way the world works now uh
and so if you can get mad at somebody
about something you're gonna find a way
to do it and you're gonna go on Twitter
and you're going to say something but
I'm just going to say firsthand we've
there's no there's no Summit for any
other platform there's no time there's
no place where you actually know
multiple people who work for this
Corporation and you know them and they
consider them oh hey so and so I've seen
you multiple times at multiple events I
kind of consider you a friend like they
are doing a good job of connecting with
and listening to the people who are the
heart and soul of their platform and I'm
going to hand it to them I mean that's
why if we can make it to events like
that we're going to we a lot of times we
can't because of our schedule but I
think it's because
you get this sense that first of all I'm
going to get to meet other people who I
can relate to who do what we do we're
going to learn things we're going to
make important connections but we're
also going to say well okay what's
coming down the line now like what is
important to YouTube right now and how
can we how does that make us better
creators on this platform and how do we
do a better job of connecting with our
fans and continuing to run a healthy
business
there's not many opportunities like that
outside that yeah and it rejuvenated
you know it it
rejuvenated my energy to continue to pay
it forward to other creators and you
know with our mythical Creator
accelerator where we're literally
investing money into other creators
businesses to help them
accelerate their building their own
brand not in the same way that we did
but in a in a similar in their own their
own to build their own version of what
we've built with mythical is an exciting
aspect of of what we're literally
investing in and so it's rewarding to
have those conversations with other
creators and know that they that it can
be a mutually beneficial relationship
and there's there's a lot more potential
there
um my one feedback for YouTube though at
a certain time it it got a little
corporate when they were like we're all
eating lunch and they're like you got to
get to the next session the next like
programming session but everybody said
the content is about to start and then
you start walking and somebody else
would say the content is this way it
felt weird it's like you okay don't you
don't use the word content so much it's
like it's a it's a session the stuff
is this way I mean this this question
the program is about to begin the thing
you're looking for is this way the
content is about to start it's like hey
you know that that word you're
stretching it too thin YouTube okay work
on it good feedback you're getting a lot
you're getting a little too
what's it called
bubbleized here one thing that I will
say
um
there's always
a little bit of Swag at these events and
there's usually a piece of
clothing and I think this year I got my
favorite one ever I brought it oh really
foreign
was not there
she did not bring swag oh he's off he's
trying to get off camera he's going to
make a reveal
there it is hello I'm very comfortable
in my robe oh what's that you say what's
my YouTube channel
Good Mythical Morning
can you read that Jenna you're exactly
right
she said you look like you're wearing a
circus tent I love this it's a terry
cloth robe that you I mean put a put a
pole in the middle of it man so are you
telling me that you could have said
there already is one well here's the
thing literally a week before the
Creator Summit I was on Amazon I go on
Amazon sometimes and other websites I'm
not just exclusive to Amazon I like that
Prime shipping though
Jeffrey Bezos looking for
robes
I got a robe I know but I don't that one
and now I got this one and here's a
hears its Rogue is that
it's not technically reversible but it
might as well be yeah you have you're
it's like you're wearing a different
color circus tent
uh
December 18th my wife's birthday in
January 1st I'm gonna wear this every
day yeah your candy cane yeah I'm a
candy cane man don't encourage him
I mean look at that I'm a CR I'm a I'm
the most relaxed Santa that's ever been
I'm like
we had fun didn't we really oh and we've
got massages
we didn't give each other massages you
didn't make that joke when we showed up
at the massage parlors to say parlor the
spa at the same time yeah that was a
that was nice it was nice yep glad you
added that yeah well I'm just saying I
saw myself this podcast is over don't
start talking about massages oh no I'm
just saying it like it was you know I
hadn't had one of those in years we got
to close this thing down yep so we have
fun I gotta is it's my wreck yeah baby
wreck baby one two three four
um
if you're into hip-hop like I am then
you already know about this I don't need
to tell you but I just want to validate
what you already know to be true is the
new j.i.d album The forever story is
really good
um so if you're if you haven't listened
to the album you should and if you have
you should watch his tiny desk concert
that NPR series
it's nice it's nice it's nice
he's he's three three nights from link
Neil all right what are we doing next
week
do we know we do know we wrote it down
but I don't know at this moment what it
is
oh we're going to be talking oh crap
what scares us the most what scares us
that's the month where you got to be
real scared of things we're going to
take your call-ins
we're prepping them up
what oh that's the week after so maybe
you can still call in
so what scares us most is next week yeah
not what scares you the most and then
what and then after that things that
have scared you the most it's gonna be
like the following week things that
you've got two redundant no because
there's people talking about like
Paranormal spooky Supernatural crazy
that's happened to you we shouldn't have
we shouldn't have these programmatic
conversations within the podcast but I
was just trying to make a legitimate
teaser
yeah uh what is it what is our number
188 earpod one and don't forget to talk
about your biscuits on the internet with
hashtag year biscuits because we will
find you and you know what have a baby I
don't give a [ __ ] hello Rhett and Link I
was just listening to your latest your
biscuits release and I really want to
thank you too for talking about local
elections you started to talk about you
know the possibility of being a mayor of
a town
um I have served on my small town city
council and I am currently running to be
in my State's legislature in the Georgia
State House of Representative
um you are very correct in saying that
these hyper local elections are
incredibly important uh if you really
want to start affecting change literally
right outside your own front door it's
not about being president of the United
States it's about being on those groups
of people that help make decisions about
how your city is developed and planned
and run you are very correct about if
you're doing it right it is an active
service that's why I like to describe
myself as a public servant rather than a
politician I'm a public servant first
and a politician second
so I will see you guys at smithicon
thanks for all you do good mythical
greetings to you my name is Matt out of
Alabama and I just thought you guys
should know that I have a recurring
dream where I travel to your studio uh
on a sweepstakes of some kind and I
desperately try to convince one of you
or Stevie to give me a job in HR for
some reason to be clear I love my job
and I don't think I would take another
offer but that's a dream I have and I
apologize I don't know hey written link
this is Paige from Detroit Michigan and
um I just wanted to let you guys know
that
um my dog with anxiety loves to listen
to you guys I mean I'd love to listen to
you guys too but she loves to listen to
you guys while I'm gone she it helps her
so much she just sits on the couch and
curls up and listens to you guys um
while I'm gone so just to let everybody
know that that your podcasts are for
dogs too okay thank you very much we
love you bye to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]